hey guys welcome new rockstars I'm Sam
basher here with another kick-ass
trailer for Luke Cage season 2 located
such a fantastic character if you wanted
reading recommendations check out New
Avengers by Brian Michael Bendis Luke is
the leader of the Avengers is so Joe but
anyway season 1 of Luke Cage is high up
on my list of favorite Netflix series
sure the second half of the show kind of
dips a bit but it's still super
entertaining on so many levels and Mike
Coulter's portrayal of Luke is just so
damn likeable and charming along with
the trailer we also got this awesome
poster with Luke Cage positioned as sort
of Atlas the Greek Titan holding Harlem
on its back so dope anyway let's hop
into it spoiler warning of course four
things here's a clip yo
I'm Luke Cage won't test me you know
where to find me what an awesome opener
with Luke's unbreakable skin comes
another helpful power in flammability no
flames for this hero no he's gonna be
okay based on how this scene plays out
I'm guessing Luke is lured to this
Merlin mattress truck which is then set
off by this man here in a very dapper
suit remember that suit comes up later
in the trailer who then gets not-so-fun
backhand I'm guessing he deserves it for
blowing up that truck I know what you're
thinking and yes there are many Merlin's
and Marvel comics but as far as Luke
Cage enemies go none that I could find
also if you notice right here on the
videographers shirt he has one of my
favorite Luke Cage designer shirts ever
next everybody talking about Cage like
he's Jesus I know I just elected mic
smoke the bulletproof black man's
for the Hard Rock's he's a gentle boogey
man of their nightmares you should get a
snack with this really guys you gotta
know we try it man I know what he's
talking about Luke Cage like he's Jesus
huh I gotta say I do love that Luke Cage
is celebrated in his community and is
proud of who he is he's just a regular
guy just trying to do the right thing
fun Easter Egg during this scene pay
attention to that giant art piece in
honor of Luke Cage a few things to knows
here first bulletproof love is the name
of the original song that Method Man
rapped on the radio in season 1 of Luke
Cage but also there's a lot of symbolism
that you should pay attention to like
the hoodie he's wearing from season one
which we learned during interviews was
meant to pay tribute to Trayvon Martin
but also the heart covered in barbed
wire which usually is meant to symbolize
the crown of thorns that Jesus wore on
the cross but also I'm guessing the
heart is symbolizing his love for his
community so yes the voiceover isn't
joking people really do look up to Luke
I would too honestly then moving forward
we see Luke wearing an awesome AC a
hoodie while also being the boogeyman of
these criminals nightmares I mean I get
it he's intimidating I love that look on
Luke's face he doesn't want to ruin any
more shirts or hoodies or anything they
gotta at least try to kill him I guess
right he's a weird thing to say but it's
a pretty funny moment but man he really
messes those guys up it's pretty awesome
next one man cannot say what community
you can't keep doing what you're doing I
have no idea what you're talking about
and believe me Luke Cage is nothing but
a man alum it's mine this is a bit of a
sad scene due to the recent passing of
Reggie caffee but I'm pretty excited to
see his role in Luke Cage season 2 he's
a fantastic actor and I'm interested to
see his relationship with Luke Cage
developed over the season can one man
save a city does it take more does that
mean there may be getting team-ups this
season we didn't get Luke carrying what
looks to be the man in that very nice
suit we knocked out Envy any of the
trailer also loose clothes look pretty
badly burned out so much torn pieces by
bullets these are the important details
that I don't miss most the time next pay
attention to this scene with the purple
lights it looks like a drug
manufacturers lair but also I think this
is a hint in a wink and a nod to us
getting one of our favorite traditions
in the Netflix Marvel world yeah one
take fight we get a piece of it here
when he's knocking guns out of bad dudes
hands but it's still very cool I hope
that just one big take also coming back
to this scene with the cop telling cage
that he can't keep doing this could this
be a nod to Captain America Civil War
possibly the sokovia accords possibly
cage can't keep fighting criminals in
the street without signing those dang
accords now like I said he's just a
normal guy I don't think he really wants
to be regulated by the UN just to save
his neighborhood or to protect his
friends and family moving forward we
also get the first encounter with one of
the big beds this season bushmaster boy
does he really mess look up but who is
Bushmaster well he doesn't have the
biggest role in comics and there are
actually two bushmasters but the one
here has similar abilities to Luke like
in the comics actually fun fact the
comic version of Bushmaster actually
tracks down Noah Bernstein the doctor
who gave Luke his powers and repeats the
process for himself the other Bushmaster
has a snake tail and giant metal swords
claws that come out of his arms I'm
gonna be honest kind of want both but
this Bushmaster will probably be good he
still has super-strength he's
invulnerable also he's played by Mustafa
Shakir who was great on the Duce next
Dam hate to see such a positive brother
like Luke Cage go down like that
you hurts you you're not invulnerable
Luke anyone who can take you on bear and
it can't be good for Harlem
so the rumors are true Luke really is
messed up after this fight boy he just
spitting up blood and everything he's
gonna need to become a better fighter
yeah this could lead to us getting iron
fist he has been confirmed for this
season so this does make sense he's not
just randomly popping up to grab a bite
to eat with Luke I am interested to see
if he's still doubt a bit from his show
and the defenders Luke Cage in full
fighting mode though is going to be sick
I'm very excited for that also damn even
ESPN is reporting on Luke Cage game
knocked out how are the Avengers not
calling on him yet
also also thank God Claire temple is
back I missed her in the Punisher and
Jessica Jones season two but happy to
see that she's back here I do love
seeing Claire and Luke together I'll be
honest I'm really excited to see maybe
Jessica and Luke patched things up once
again and possibly get together in the
comics they're married can they have a
little baby named Danielle she's
adorable and she grows up in one random
future where she becomes Captain America
see these things are important
real quick pay attention to this quick
clip here we see Luke and Bushmaster on
a bridge together looking like they're
getting ready to throw down
but hopefully we're not getting the
tease of a final confrontation in the
very first trailer next I'm gonna find
him who makes him so scary
you hope you never have to find out
it's my wish miss don't come so Lucas
thrown that hoodie back on to go save
Harlem hell yeah next we see Bushmaster
surrounded by candles and based on the
editing and the super strength that used
to crack that sink I'm guessing that
bushmasters abilities might be slightly
different in the show compared to his
comic book counterpart I'm guessing that
his powers are from magic or something
mystical based on this ritual magic
isn't new to the Marvel Netflix room
after the reveal that the hand uses
dragon bones to gain immortality also
worth mentioning it looks like
bushmasters invulnerability doesn't
quite work the same as Luke Cage it
looks like he can take some shots to his
body but they also look like they're
embedded in his skin and not just
bouncing off he's probably gonna be okay
the guy who's not gonna be okay is the
one getting a knife into the eye next
[Music]
I've seen you raw they're never brutal
sometimes pretending to get [ __ ] done
[Music]
we see Luke caves bursting out of some
doors at the bushmasters hideout or at
least one of his hideouts which leads to
one of Luce classic costume
accoutrements the chain Luke has used
the chain as a belt for decades in the
comic world we even get a hint of it in
season 1 for just a second and that's
all I needed but also he uses it as a
weapon sometimes he even wraps around
his arm as a shield for his forearm like
a gauntlet then cut to a montage of Luke
kicking all kinds of us that leads to
Bushmaster taking on Luke and one of our
favorite bars with the not so bright
past
Harlem's paradise this club does get to
play a role in season 2 which is
exciting and we get a glimpse of it
again later on so hold tight but pay
attention to that kick that Bushmaster
is landing right in the middle of Luke's
chest it looks like another person is
about to take a tumble out of that
second-story window
alright P cottonmouth it also looks like
Luke's may be getting a little extra
violent this season maybe you need to
get a little brutal to get the job done
the next flip we get is up a band
playing and thank God because that means
the music is gonna play a pivotal role
just like in season 1 in season 2 also
with a little shot of Harlem's paradise
that means we're probably gonna see the
return of two characters from last
season Mariah and shades and in a couple
seconds we actually do see them so
that's pretty cool Alfre Woodard and
Theo Rossi are back and it looks like
they just burn down Luke's apartment or
possibly Claire's apartment i under way
that's kind of mean but hey if they
really want to send a message this would
do it next home doesn't need a hero it'd
be snuggly the darkness that you deal
with every day
we can't conceal and behold
you bet
don't let
oh we're gonna shot similar to season
ones cottonmouth with his head lining up
with the portrait of biggie symbolizing
that he was going to be king but now
mariah is stepping up most likely taking
over cottonmouths organization you know
want to mess with Mariah I'm gonna be
honest or with Shades who's back with
his classic shades and a haircut one of
these days we're finally gonna get laser
shooting out of his eyes or his shades
the very least I'm happy we're getting
that portrait of biggie one more time
next pay attention to the insignia on
the design for Misty's arm that would be
Rand industries the company owned by
Danny ran the immortal Iron Fist
protector of Carlinville that guy he
said a fifty thousand times in two
different shows the arm does look pretty
cool though and I'm excited to see it
improve over this season and future
seasons get full cybernetic like it is
in the comics they've even let it hack
into computers like cyborg can next we
see a super powerful gun aimed it what
looks to be Luke Cage but I'm guessing
these are two different shots edited
together that kind of weapon might knock
the wind out of Luke if I'm being honest
but it shouldn't hurt him shouldn't cut
his skin but this led me to thinking do
you think we're gonna see any more of
those exploding alien bullets from
season one possibly but next we see
Bushmaster and Luke fighting like
actually fighting fighting not just Luke
just you know throwing punches so maybe
this is after he's learned a thing or
two from the immortal iron fist they're
moving on we see what looks to be shades
sneaking around in an apartment heavily
armed could this be lucre Claire's
apartment I also see Mariah getting
pissed and throwing her drink my guess
is that season two will see the downfall
of Mariah and shades cuz she can't keep
getting away with all these evil deeds
my theory is backed up by the shot of
armed cops running into a Harlem
paradise but based on the shot of shades
with that same weaponry this could just
be Mariah's people maybe she hired these
guards also Claire and Luke dancing
together just need to point this out
there are two pretty people who are
happy together I think that should be
celebrated also last shot I want to
point out before the title credit Mariah
seems absolutely done we've had all and
takes a gun herself who she find her
that well I'm not really sure we'll have
to wait and see then we get a kick-ass
Luke Cage logo with one last word from
Cathy's character who looks to have
already changed his tune about Luke
asking him not to let the darkness get
into his soul one more clip for you guys
let's go I'm not the market for
sike - it says you're not my sidekick
me it's my show let's all agree that
misty is the best awesome tea is to see
her mechanical arm in action doesn't
have all the bells and whistles like the
one in the comics but I am excited to
see this story unfold this season also a
great fourth wall breaking joke
it's Luca show but also let's be honest
it's Missy show Luke and Misty really
made season 1 very special and fantastic
well that's it how do you think Luke is
gonna take down Bushmaster are you
excited to see Danny Rand you can lie
about it and be excited in the comments
I won't judge let me know down below or
on Twitter I hats and basher also you
can check out my podcast don't stupid
answers while you're at it be sure to
LIKE this video share and subscribe for
more breakdowns and whatnot and I'll see
you guys next time bye bye
[Music]